dragonball is remembered for this
[Music]
however believe it or not this is what I
think of what I say Dragon Ball
I don't think of climactic battles
transformations or even world ending
attacks
I think of snake way and I don't mean
that in a negative way either
I loved its depiction of other world I
loved the misadventures Goku lost
himself 8 on his way to King Kai's I
just loved the concept of it all but
something that has bothered me is the
notion that anything outside a fight
scene or main plot lines somehow is
considered a waste of time or
significantly less valuable and I'm not
sure if I necessarily agree with that
sentiment when I was a kid growing up
for me waiting had always been an
essential part of what makes a dragon
ball fight scene exciting an epic
however lately I begun to ask myself the
question how important if at all is it
today I want to take you on the journey
I took to answer that very question and
like any journey a million miles or not
it begins with the first step
in the original run of Dragon Ball Goku
spends 12 episodes on snake way before
arriving at King Kai's planet in the
Dragon Ball Kai cut of the series the
journey takes only three in order to
achieve this episode coach the following
had to be cut
Goku's time spent with the street
cleaner which was in and of itself a
fantastic gag his accidental falling
into Hell where he met and challenged
gods and meds for safe passage out of
hell
princess snakes palace and his escape
from it and finally finding himself in
King Emma's desk having to start the
whole run all over again which never
fails to make me laugh
the same streamlining process was
implemented throughout the show and
therefore arcs like the Saiyan saga that
were once 35 episodes in Japanese and 26
in English were edited down to 17
episodes in both languages with the
release of Dragon Ball Kai this brought
the anime closer to the mangas telling
of the story this is all perfectly fine
however I don't think it's fair to say
all of what I listed before that was cut
had no value I think that's ridiculous
it enriches the world with character and
personality and genuinely without all of
that it feels significantly more barren
and
but mainly what this all has taught me
is that most people hate to wait a lot
of people don't care about what happens
leading up they just want to see the big
moments in a day and age where youtubers
upload multiple long videos every single
day 365 days a year
where Netflix uploads entire seasons of
TV shows to binge from start to finish
the idea of having to delay
gratification for the sake of something
like story is what many fans today's
struggle with which to me is a shame
because I think part of what makes a
journey fund is the journey not the
destination
to prove my point let's take a look at
three of the most popular scenes from
the original dragon ball story to see
how waiting played an important role in
their success
Gamboa
doc ascetically when we the audience
were first introduced to the Prince of
all Saiyans instantly Vegeta became the
symbol of evil in Dragon Ball it wasn't
until we saw how resourceful and nuanced
his character was did we begin to warm
up to him and find him intensely
compelling we watched him suffer and
grow make mistakes and learn because of
this he became one of if not the most
popular character in the entire series
culminating with this scene having been
raised to believe a false set of
ideologies Vegeta's path to redemption
was wrought with turmoil sacrifice and
suffering it was a long journey the
longest character arc in the entire
series by a wide margin
it was the consequences of experiences
and choices Vegeta made that acted as
the building blocks to his character
arcs climax do you think the character
of Vegeta would have been nearly as
compelling and well-received if his
entire story had been condensed into a
single arc due to King Piccolo's actions
over the course of an entire arc he
became known as a malicious and
reprehensible villain as the arc came to
a close we were introduced to piccolo
jr. later referred to simply as piccolo
what initially made this character
interesting was who he was associated
with and because of his association he
then filled the role of Goku's nemesis
in the closing arc of Dragon Ball
however as time moved forward natural
and organic circumstances arose forcing
piccolo to make certain important
choices the consequences of these
choices ultimately led him to share with
us the audience a much-needed catharsis
for his character what made piccolo
compelling as a character were the
circumstances that preceded him the evil
doctrine he was born into and ultimately
the compromises he needed to make over
the course of his entire lifetime in
order to become the person he was
supposed to be this could not have been
told over the course of a small number
of episodes or even an arc it needed
time Gohan or little Mata money shove it
to allah almighty and lastly this
scene
[Music]
this from what I've been exposed to is
widely considered the favorite isolated
moment among fans from the entire series
however as I'm certain you are all aware
of it started here Gohan is a fantastic
example of someone who physically and
emotionally benefited from enough time
passing over a significant portion of
his life Gohan's experiences led him
down a path where he realized he was
worth much more than he ever thought
possible
whether it be against Raddatz nappa
Vegeta his adventures on Namek or even
Frieza Donna throughout Gohan story are
these pockets of performance and rage he
is more than just that of course but
pertaining to that quote great scene in
question hypothetically if you were to
view that clip in isolation without any
backstory it might look cool but it
would not be memorable or impactful the
same way because you didn't experience
the story alongside the character in
other words you never experienced his
struggle - you wouldn't be able to
empathize the point I'm trying to make
with all of these examples is that
despite Dragonball being remembered for
these moments despite the overwhelming
consensus being that Dragonball is great
because of flashy transformations and
big set pieces in reality in actuality
it's great because of the careful
planning and time that went into each
and every one of these characters to
show what I'm talking about doesn't just
relate or pertain to Dragonball
exclusively but to every story medium
let's take a look at a company that
makes a living off of promoting fight
scenes and creating these monumental
moments that need to be great World
Wrestling Entertainment's
[Music]
there's a term in wrestling called
booking this is referring to the means
by which the characters on the show are
scheduled and written to win or lose
otherwise known as their storyline it is
widely accepted within wrestling circles
that long-term booking is far more
favorable than short-term booking this
is essentially comparing long term
storytelling or stories told over a long
period of time to short-term
flash-in-the-pan stories WWE has
hundreds if not thousands of matches
every year but the biggest event on the
WWE calendar is WrestleMania in mid to
late spring WWE holds the event that
acts as the climax to a year's worth of
storytelling often times it acts as the
conclusion to many stories the big
showdown in a show like WrestleMania you
can't just have a main event with no
long term storytelling or booking and if
you do it just wouldn't work there needs
to be a compelling story to draw people
in the characters need to have a
motivation and a motivation comes from a
what their four characters need to want
something in order to fight and you can
communicate that over time through story
to your audience Vegeta wants revenge
against Frieza for the death of his
people
Goku wants to test himself against
strong opponents piccolo wants to
protect his family and Gohan wants to
keep his friends safe one example of
what I'm talking about is best
illustrated when discussing the
tournament of power during the show's
airing the consensus was that the show
was moving far too slowly and that there
was perhaps too much unneeded filler
however during every pivotal moment in
the tournament of power whether it be
the first universe's elimination the two
parts special Goku's fight with kale or
the ending that vocal portion of the fan
base that was complaining by and large
enjoyed what was transpiring on-screen
similarly many folks myself included
this time had serious problems with the
pacing of the Dragon Ball super manga
everything was happening far far too
quickly which as a result completely
ruined not only the endings sense of
suspense and tension but the entire arc
as a whole
in contrast the end to the animes
telling of the tournament of power was a
worldwide event the
three episodes had hundreds of thousands
of people over various parts of the
world watching the culmination of the
tournament unfold before their eyes why
because it was a spectacle there was a
sense of atmosphere tension and stakes
it paste itself correctly and earned
each and every moment it presented my
point is we put too much emphasis on
these monumental moments without
appreciating the time that's needed to
make these moments work as well as they
do
Super Saiyan Blue's unveiling was not
nearly as impactful as the original
Super Saiyan or even ultra instinct
because it never earned that moment
whereas the others did
Super Saiyan blue just showed up
expecting that to be enough and it just
wasn't the same
however despite everything when all is
said and done Dragon Ball will be
remembered for these moments these epic
larger-than-life moments snapshots in
time that will fill those that watch
them with nostalgia for the good old
days and so fans will always yearn for
more moments like these more and more
frequently not understanding or
appreciating that these in isolation are
not what makes Dragon Ball great it's
the story that makes these moments what
they are without the necessary context
these moments mean nothing but when give
it enough time and the right story they
excite us make us cheer laugh and cry so
when you're watching your favorite show
are looking back on your favorite
moments from a series try to keep in
mind appreciate and above all else
remember
the importance of waiting thanks for
watching
[Music]